the north stream 2 gas pipeline has
proven a contentious topic in u.s
european relations but washington this
week said it was dropping its opposition
to the project
after reaching a deal with berlin the
pipeline's supposed to
double the volume of gas delivered to
germany via the baltic sea but critics
say it will give russia
too much scope to control energy
supplies to ukraine
or other european nations dw's moscow
bureau chief talked to
former russian president dmitry medvedev
about it
the kremlin is one of the biggest
stakeholders in the german-american deal
former russian president dmitry medvedev
told dw
that the agreement would pave the way
for the completion of nordstream 2.
positive words even though the agreement
pledges action if russia uses the
pipeline as a weapon
to disrupt gas flows through ukraine
even though we don't like a few
formulations and there are a couple of
clauses on sanctions
it's still better than destroying a
nearly finished project that is so
important for europe
and you're not afraid of a couple of
clauses sanctions as you say if russia
were to stop transporting gas through
ukraine
if someone imposes sanctions we would
survive
but i think something else is happening
right now
we're seeing european and american
politicians performing a ritual dance
to recognize the fact that the nordstrom
2 project has succeeded
rejects the criticism from nordstrom 2
opponents
that the pipeline will leave germany too
dependent on russia
for its energy needs
you can never be too dependent when it
comes to trade
trade is always mutual if germany is
dependent on russian gas supplies
then russia is dependent on the market
prices
and certain delivery volumes being
approved
medvedev is convinced that the nordstrom
2 project is not political but rather
commercial
he feels that the u.s created
difficulties on the path to completion
out of its own self-interest
at a certain point our interests clashed
with those of the united states
washington realized it's much more
profitable to supply europe with its own
liquid gas
and earn money doing it the americans
applied pressure
and noise stream 2 became problematic
these problems are down to u.s economic
interests
and its attempts to profit from the
european market
moscow says it regrets that germany and
the us agreed their deal without
russia's participation
kremlin speaker dimitri piskov compared
it to holding a wedding without the
groom
and rejected the accusation that russia
had ever used the supply of natural gas
as a political instrument
you